are you a Halloween fan do you are you
one of those guys that still as an adult
dresses up and go out and yeah I can
always wear my [ __ ] outfit on
Halloween do you go out as [ __ ] yeah a
nurse yeah I know you know my dad my dad
was obsessed with Halloween I was like
when I was a kid he was obsessed with
designing the costumes for me and my
sister and he would really like I was
like one year I was like a cranberry
juice box you know wait what a what yeah
like an ocean and Ocean Spray cranberry
juice box like like a cardboard box my
size of my body with a straw that was
made out of cardboard you know and like
and the painting and I wore a white
spandex suit and like my hands came out
of it and you put the candy in the straw
and it was a whole thing was a whole
thing
sorry I'm sorry I'm sure this was an
impressive-looking costume but I don't
know many kids were like I'm gonna be in
well that's just the beginning I mean
that's just vanning yeah no no it wasn't
like hey Dad I want to be a superhero
he's like all right cool whatever and
then we did it and he was like got all
your candy and then I went to sleep and
whatever it was like a month-long Pramod
aid towards Halloween with like it does
we designed it there was like there were
drawings and then we ended up yeah and
then every day after I finished my
homework I had to do it with him and
stuff and it was I was I was an Oreo
cookie once that was uh that was like
you know soft that soft sort of foam and
and he cut it out like it looked like a
3d Oreo cookie and I wore again white
spandex just wanted to be white
I'm seeing here yeah here I'm yeah I'm
gonna be only white spandex but the and
then the ultimate one he did was I was a
house one year and I I a house I was a
house that was like a realistic looking
house so yeah I mean I wha it was a
house with different scenes in each
window and there were lights that lid it
up and I were a backpack battery
yeah battery it's not even done and it
fit on top of my head I could only see
out of the one window it's the chimney
was where you put the candy in I
couldn't I could not hear a thing
like I couldn't walk in it and my dad
was so proud of himself it was like we
walk down the street and I would hear
like kerplunk kerplunk and I'd see candy
that I couldn't get at because because
the chimney was attached but it was like
not that way it was that way it was so
where was the candy going was it candy
go into like a chamber
[Applause]
you